right-hander tyler glass now our
starting pitchers and tyler was making
his ninth start of the season looking
for his fifth win
2.37 on the earned run average 75 punch
outs in 49 and a third innings and he
does it in a in a way that's very
efficient just over 15 and a half
pitches and inning first pitch of the
night is a fastball popped up and to
shallow right center field the shift was
on brasso and adamus coming together
with two outfielders and it is brasso to
make the catch here's francisco lindor
and to cut the mess he is out on three
pitches and dwayne he showed him all
three the three major pitches for the
new york mets is going to be left-hander
david peterson making his seventh start
of the season and the numbers bear this
out it's been an up and down season for
david peterson he had a good start a bad
start a good start a bad start the day
that the rays clinched the american
league east they were at citi field they
beat the mets and rosarina hit two home
runs that day and it was something of a
foreshadowing of what was going to
happen in the postseason when he hit 10
home runs in 20 postseason games that's
a bouncing ball up the middle but right
where the second baseman perazo was and
from the right of the bag he throws out
a rosarina one man away margo who has
stolen four and been caught twice will
measure his lead from first the 1-1 with
the runner going taking low mccann's
throw on one hop and out is the call at
second lindor pumping his fist as mccann
made a strong throw lindor applies the
tag
and margot
is caught stealing and that keeps david
peterson's record intact peterson has
not given up a stolen base in his major
league career and so now the rays have
the bases loaded
with one man out the third baseman kevin
podlow coming up and padlow gets a
fastball and pops it up alonzo chasing
it
and gets to it but can't grab it
if he had caught it diaz might have
scored from third he didn't drop it
intentionally but it did pop out of his
glove and they will not charge an error
no they should not charge an error here
oh goes down swinging peterson with a
huge strikeout gets kevin potlow
blessing for the mets if alonso makes
that catch a run scores most likely but
now peterson gets the strikeout instead
now if he retires brett phillips the
mets get out of the inning without a run
scored strung out and missed strike
three got him with a slider side retired
peterson works out of a huge jam and the
raise problems with runners in scoring
position continue so now randy arose
arena leads off the third serena grounds
sharply to third diving stop vr gets up
throws to first pick by alonso for the
owl jonathan vr with a beautiful diving
stab on a rocket off the band of a rose
arena
shot to his feed made a low throw to
first and then tampa's own pete alonso
with a pick to get the out on a rosarena
yeah which play do you like better kyle
glass now perfect through three
jeff mcneal leads off the fourth and
there's a swing and a miss out number
one here in the fourth and it's the
fourth strikeout for last night no score
here in the top of the fourth to pitch
to the door swung out and missed strike
three another slow breaking fish from
lindor he's out on strikes for the
second time two going here in the fourth
here's michael conforto just wanted to
lift it toward left and it's gonna hang
up there long enough for a rosarian to
go down to a knee another one two three
inning for glass now he's perfect
through four now the mets with an
infield hit have their first base runner
and now jonathan vr will be the batter
and vr launches one out to right field
back goes mark go to the warning track
at the wall
and it's out of here
jonathan vr with a two-run homer to put
the mets in front and again as wayne
said if you're gonna get glasnow
you better take them deep vrs hit a
second home run of the year it's the
seventh allowed by glasnow this year he
was perfect until the pilar infield
single and now another of the benchmob
jonathan vr comes through and it's two
to nothing new york well david peterson
has been tremendous tonight two men away
and that'll bring up the number three
hitter austin meadows a left-handed
batter slapped on the ground vr
sidearms to first in time to get meadows
and that's 14 straight retired by david
peterson james mccann who
singled in the fifth wins now has hit
double figures
in strikeouts in four
separate games
so far this year and
there's nine right now throwing and
grounded back up toward the middle
ranging to his left is willie his
off-balance throw is low but handled
nicely by yandi and that will retire the
side that's a nice tiny three-up
three-down inning for tyler glass now 16
in a row retired by peterson williams
will be the batter he growls this one
right to vr at third he has it swings it
across to alonso a little bit high but
pete brings it down and the inning is
over david peterson has now retired 17
straight well one out nobody on for
mcneal who is nothing out of three left
hand better the infield is overshifted
and it's driven in the air to left
center on the run phillips won't get it
it's in for a hit goes to the wall
phillips plays it on the warning track
and mcneil moving somewhat carefully
is standing at second with a double and
understandably because he cramped up a
few days ago or a couple of nights ago
anyway
and at that point
was given the rest of that game off the
day after had the off day yesterday and
was not going to risk blowing it out
well the mets looking to build on a
two-nothing lead mcneil in scoring
position with one out francisco will
endure the batter and cutting the miss
he strikes down lindor for the third
time tonight ten strikeouts for glantz
now
and more importantly the second out here
in the eight swinging the grounder up
the first base line it's fair handled by
yandi he'll go to the bag himself and
that will retire the side so what a job
by
tyler blaster david peterson flirting
with some extraordinary stuff 17
straight retired
and now pitching in the eighth inning
for the first time in his career
he'll take on the lower third of the
order mike zanino leads off for the rays
[Applause]
[Music]
touches off another one
it's his eighth home run of the season
to the razor on the board it's two to
one the tang run at second base where's
manuel margot swinging a line right
there down the third base line this will
tie the game into the corner it goes
padlow scores margot in a second with an
rbi double it's two to two it's either
going to extras or it ends here phillips
has struck out all three times today in
the first pitch swing line drive base
hit right field the rays win and brent
phillips sends everybody home
it's the first walk-off win of the year
for the race and brett phillips is
airplaning in center field here at
tropicana field the race with two in the
eighth and one in the ninth